est-il facile en 2018 de voler une
voiture pour trouver une réponse nous
sommes allés à l'école polytechnique de
montréal rencontrer l'équipe du
professeur josé fernández dans le vol de
voitures
avec la nouvelle technique avec les
technologies qu'on utilise maintenant de
porte-clés sans fil à il y a plusieurs
scénarios possibles de vol premier
scénario déverrouiller la portière d'un
véhicule pour déverrouiller une voiture
sans clé nader à marie l'assistant de
recherche à polytechnique s'est équipé
d'un appareil capable de capter maîtres
signal radio et d'un logiciel pour
enregistrer signal qui aimait la clé
sont neutres et concédé qu'elle son
contrat après seulement quelques tests
dans son laboratoire
nader pouvait intercepté le signal de la
clé de notre camionnette est verrouillé
et la déverrouiller sans aucune
difficulté
venez de voir ça prend quelques secondes
jusqu'à tes signal rejoignent donc faut
pas qu'on doit commettre ce délit
l'équipement tout aussi peu qu'une
cinquantaine de dollars
et pas besoin d'un expert pour savoir
l'utiliser la clé en métal est en train
de disparaître
aujourd'hui on porte des dispositifs
électroniques sur soi et dès qu'on
approche le véhicule et la porte des
bars et on peut démarrer
mais avec ces systèmes sans clé il y a
des failles et les voleurs savent très
bien les exploiter
si la porte clés sur la table à café de
salon et puis le voleur se trouve à
proximité de la voiture il peut avec ce
qu'on appelle un amplificateur de signal
faire croire aux porte-clés qu'il est
dans la voiture
à ce moment-là a forcé le porte-clés
envoyer le signal qui déverrouille la
voiture
partir de ce moment là le voleur peut
partir avec la voiture en présence de
nos moutons un start&stop encore là
l'équipement pour effectuer ce qu'on
appelle des attaques relais ne coûtent
que quelques centaines de dollars
il serait théoriquement possible de
faire des porte-clés pour voitures qui
sont aussi sécuritaire que les
transactions qu'on a sur internet
aujourd'hui si les manufacturiers
automobiles et les fabricants de pièces
investissent et peut-être quelques
dollars de plus par pour chaque
porte-clés à la paie acp
on a été déçus de voir la disparition la
vieille clé mécanique qu'on devait
inséré dans une série pour la tournée
parce qu'on se dit c'est une ligne de
défense qui disparaît tu disparais ces
gens là on a seulement une protection
purement électronique alors c'est clair
qu'une protection purement électronique
peut se déjouer à distance et ça c'est
inquiétant
un voleur prend moins d'une minute pour
voler une voiture au pays
500 véhicules sont volés par jour les
statistiques démontrent que le vol
d'automobile revient en importance et
aussi que le taux de récupération de
véhicules volés et allah est à la baisse
et la maison finalement c'est que le vol
est plus professionnelle est souvent les
véhicules quittent le pays rêvé que les
plus convoités selon le bureau
d'assurance du canada le nombre de vols
a grimpé de 7 % au québec en 2010 est
une première en dix ans toutefois la
valeur moyenne d'un vol n'a jamais cessé
d'augmenter elle est passée de 14 mille
dollars en 2007 à près de 20 mille dix
ans plus tard on estime qu'à peine un
véhicule volé sur dix est retrouvé
c'est là qu'on voit en ce moment la
liste des véhicules les plus volés
introduit quelques véhicules dotés en
valeur à l'intérieur d'une liste de
véhicules populaires c'est parce qu'on
ne le marché de l'exportation qui vient
d'arriver où on ne peut plus aujourd'hui
en 2018 construire des systèmes de
contrôle des systèmes de sécurité cinq
ans sans prendre en compte la mène
informatique l'industrie automobile
quand il est question de vol ne vois pas
ça comme principalement si sa
responsabilité mais est ce que le
fabricant et que perdre un de se faire
voler ses véhicules la réponse est non
là bas on a compris qui fabrique un
haïtien pour le vol par sa férule
élémentaire et pour eux c'est des
nouvelles ventes
mais si le nombre de vols de voitures
augmentent trop le risque c'est de voir
bien sûr les compagnies d'assurance
augmenter leurs primes et quand les
primes augmentent trop à leur tour aider
le consommateur réagit ici seulement
quand les consommateurs en ont assez
qu'on adopte de nouvelles normes et que
l'industrie automobile réagir